[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHAD JENNINGS: My
name is Chad Jennings.
I'm a product
manager for BigQuery.
And I've been one
of the spear headers
for the inclusion of
GIS inside of BigQuery.
And so I am beyond delighted to
be presenting this story to you
all this morning,
partially because I
think BigQuery is
awesome, partially
because I think GIS in
BigQuery is awesome, but more
because the story that we
have to show to you today
is just absolutely worth the
next 42 minutes of your life.
Also, a couple of public
service announcements.
In the app, please do--
there's a Dory.
So at the end, we'll be
moderating questions.
The Dory questions will
come from the front mic.
If there any folks
with questions,
you can use the rear mic.
But if you've got questions, go
ahead and enter them as we go.
We'll keep that Dory open
for two weeks after the talk.
So it's a place for
continued conversation.
All right.
Well, that having been said,
let's go ahead and launch.
So one of the reasons
that Google folks like
to work at Google is making
the impossible possible
is a mantra that we
have inside the company.
And GIS inside of
BigQuery really
exemplifies that capability.
We've been able to unblock
some very significant workloads
for customers as Andreas
Heim from Unacast shows here.
What we're doing today--
or what an exciting announcement
that we're doing today is we're
announcing that general
availability of BigQuery GIS.
So we launched the beta
back a few months ago.
And the adoption has
been absolutely stellar.
And with general
availability, you actually
get quite a number
of new features
that we'll get into
in just a second.
Geospatial data.
It's interesting.
If you live in the Google
world, web logs are everything.
Right?
Because Google lives
and breathes web logs.
But when you start talking
about particular industries,
especially talking to people
in those particular industries,
geospatial data emerges
as a critical unblocker
for very specific workloads.
So across a number of these
different industries mentioned
out here on the
slide, geospatial
enables folks to get more
questions answered that
just weren't possible before.
We'll dive in detail in the
public sector and IoT branches.
But in addition to
that, geospatial data
is also the cornerstone
of pretty much
every ecological
study ever done.
So let me see if I can guide the
mouse to the right place here.
There we go.
So what Greg Fiske
has done, who's
an analyst at the
Woods Hole Research
Center, is he has plotted
all of the ship traffic--
the circumpolar ship traffic.
And so this video
shows the recession--
the annual recession and
progression of the polar ice
cap.
And the blue and yellow
tracks show ship traffic here.
And one thing that Greg
noticed through this
is, A, the obvious one is
that every summer the ice
cap recedes a little
bit further than it
did the year before and
that the polar vessels are
able to traverse a
little bit further north.
The keen eye among
you as well might
have noticed some blue traces
that go right through the ice.
Those are ice breakers.
So you can do that.
There's even one-- there it is.
It goes right to the North Pole.
That's a $25,000 per
person tourist ride
that you can get from
Novosibirsk, just
in case you were wondering
if that's an option.
And so as they look
at these tracks,
they found that the
shipping traffic was moving
further and further north.
And the volume of
the shipping traffic
was getting higher as these
waters are getting easier
to navigate.
And so they're using that
data to advise policymakers
for things like, how long should
the hake fishing season be?
How long should we be
fishing for halibut?
What should the transit
regulations be up in the north?
And having BigQuery
GIS has enabled
Greg to do work that he wouldn't
be able to do otherwise.
All right.
OK.
So what's new since the beta?
First and foremost,
perhaps most importantly
and least excitingly, the
transition from beta to GA
means these features are now
fully backed by a BigQuery
service level agreement.
So they have the
full weight and force
of Google Cloud behind
them now that they're GA.
It goes a lot faster than
it did six months ago.
So I hope you're
all enjoying that.
We've also, to make it
simply easier to use,
expanded the number of files
that we import and egress.
We've added a lot more functions
over the course of the last six
months.
By the way, my favorite
here is the safe prefix.
This includes not just geography
functions but other functions
inside of BigQuery.
But if you do safe dot,
instead of that query,
if it comes upon some invalid
data in the course of running
the query, it will actually
not fail the query, just
return null for that
particular moment.
So it's a really handy
trick for debugging.
I highly recommend it.
And then kind of
more fun here is
we've also added a
geospatial support
for k-means clustering, which
launched yesterday in BQML.
And so our Mickey
Mouse animation
here shows that you can
now do clustering with ML
on your geospatial data.
That actually doesn't happen
in any other platform,
which I think is awesome.
And lastly, BigQuery
GeoViz, which
was our very lightweight
visualization engine,
has now gotten a little
bit more heavyweight.
And we've increased
the amount of data
that folks can visualize by 25x.
So get in and play
with that tool.
That'll be a lot
of fun for folks.
Also, supporting usage.
Public data sets.
There are an enormous
number of public data sets
that have geospatial
information in them.
So you don't even have
to bring your own data.
There's a lot of
interesting work
to be done right from these.
Also, the first column
here-- the rightmost one--
US boundaries, if
we go ahead and take
the trouble of
importing the shape
file to have all the county
boundaries, or the state
boundaries in the United
States, or zip codes,
or census tracts--
you get the pattern here--
then you don't have
to worry about it.
It's only just a join away.
So BigQuery, the technology
that we've invented here
between BigQuery GIS and
GeoViz, as I stated before,
is making the
impossible possible.
And when you put
technology in the hands
of enormously creative and
enormously skilled customers,
like Aclima and Geotab, you
get some really amazing stuff.
And let me tell you
a very short story
about how amazing stuff
lands today when it
started not quite a year ago.
So June last year,
I called Mike, who
you'll meet in just a moment.
And I said, hey, we're
launching-- don't tell anybody,
but we're launching
GIS and we're launching
ML inside of BigQuery.
Do you want to play?
And Mike said, oh, that
actually sounds awesome.
Seven weeks later, Geotab
was on stage here at Next,
telling the world about how
these two technologies that
literally didn't exist
in the public seven weeks
before, how they could
operate together.
So that level of innovation
was quite impressive.
So we launched that
in July last year.
Around about that same
time, Felipe Hoffa,
from our developer relations
team, said, you know what?
Aclima, Geotab,
y'all should talk.
And they did.
And when you put folks
together who want to talk
and want to develop
together, they actually
created the system that I
won't describe because I
don't want to give it away.
But they created the
system that we're
going to go into detail here.
Roughly simultaneously
with this,
Google sales kind of got
wind of this and said,
wow, I can make this--
Chad can do the tech side.
But I can put this into the
hands of a lot of customers.
So thank you very much.
So anyway, they developed
a go to market strategy.
And we're actually here able to
announce the first deal where
San Mateo County is going to
use the system that Geotab
and Aclima have developed.
So from innovation, through
product development,
through go to market, to first
deal closed in 10 months.
I think that's an awesome story.
And now to tell you
what that story actually
is, Davida Herzl from Aclima.
Please.
DAVIDA HERZL: Thank
you so much, Chad.
And thank you everybody.
So air pollution is
now a global epidemic.
92% of the world is
breathing unhealthy air.
That translates to seven million
premature deaths per year,
which is greater than homicides
and traffic accidents combined.
And it's not just these
staggering numbers as
related to mortality.
Air pollution is affecting
quality of life for people
every single day.
It's connected not only
to asthma and other forms
of respiratory disease
but increasingly
a wide number of other
human health impacts
like Alzheimer's, diabetes.
It's even connected to higher
incidences of crime in cities.
And this is costing
us big money.
In the US alone, air pollution
cost us $866 billion last year.
And to address this
problem, it really
comes down to a simple mantra.
We have to measure
what we manage
and manage what we measure.
But current measuring
approaches are really
insufficient to address
the scale of the problem.
It's challenging to understand
exactly where emissions
are coming from and
who is being affected
with the current model of
measurement infrastructure
that is deployed across
the United States,
but also around the
world, that relies
on traditional
methods of measurement
that translate into very large
equipment that's not connected
to the internet, is
difficult to deploy.
And so you end up with
a very sparse deployment
of these measurement
sites across cities.
In the city of San
Francisco, for example,
there is one monitor
for the entire city.
But in fact, now, thanks
to work that we've
been doing for the last several
years, which I will talk
about, it's critical that
we work towards a future
where we have data and
information about emissions
at a hyper-local scale
and providing data that
is relevant and actionable.
So Aclima has been working
for the last 10 years
to really realize this vision
of ubiquitous air quality data
and climate emissions data so
that we can really take action
at the local scale.
Air pollution, climate change,
these are global issues.
But solutions happen locally in
our cities, and our counties,
and our states, and
our communities.
Solving the challenge of
actually delivering block
by block data is an
incredibly difficult technical
and scientific challenge.
And so Aclima has invested
nearly 10 years of R and D
into unlocking this capability.
We started in 2008
and have really
reached a monumental milestone
in the last couple of years
with very strong
scientific validation
behind our methodology and
acceptance of our methodology,
broadly in the scientific
community, which
really provides the basis for
accelerated global scaling.
We've been working
with Google since 2010.
And so our partnership
with Google
has been evolving
over the years,
and really excited about
where we are today.
We deliver a unified platform.
So we're delivering
best-in-class mobile and
stationary sensors
that really work
to deliver the highest
possible level of data quality
from small scale sensors.
We provide end-to-end
network management,
so we manage the
entire network, and all
of the data management
and analytics
on the back end,
which runs on GCP.
And we make all
of that available
in an easy-to-access SAS
platform for our customers
to really empower our customers
to take action to reduce
emissions and reduce exposure.
And really, one of the core
enablers of city scale mapping
is our proven methodology that
leverages connected vehicles.
So we're really taking
advantage of the trends
in connected vehicles to use
roving fleets of vehicles
as a roving sensor network.
And we've done some
really fantastic work
over the last several
years with Google,
and Google Street View,
Google Earth Outreach,
and a number of
scientific partners
to validate this
methodology that
results in representative
maps of hyper-local hotspots
and sources as well
as areas of exposure.
And so we're now
working with fleets
to scale our data
collection platform,
to scale the mapping platform
to deliver this data to cities
around the world.
And last year we
announced-- last September
we announced that we're taking
our partnership with Google
and Google Street
View Global, which
is a really exciting development
in our journey with Google,
which we're incredibly
just over the moon about,
to really bring
this information,
again, to millions and billions
of people around the world.
You can actually see a
live demo of data streaming
in from the Street View fleet
at the Bigtable showcase.
And now we're
working with fleets
beyond Street View
and other fleets
to expand and scale
our efforts, which
is why we're so
excited to be working
with Geotab, one of the
leaders in fleet telematics.
So with that, Mike, I'll
hand it over to you.
Thank you.
MIKE BRANCH: Thank
you so much, Davida.
I'll just put this
mic down over here.
So first of all, I'm really
excited to be here today
to talk about two really
synergistic technologies
that I think together
have the power
to really be transformative.
So quickly about Geotab, we
are the world's second largest
telematics company.
We have about 35,000 different
customers across the globe
right now.
And we are available
in commercial fleet.
So a fleet might range in
size from 1 to 100,000.
And typically, these
commercial fleets
use us for a few
different purposes.
So they'll use us from
a safety perspective,
from a compliance perspective,
from a productivity
perspective.
And we've got a little device.
And it plugs into
the vehicle into
the onboard diagnostic port.
And it tracks everything
from windshield wiper
activation through to engine our
RPM, through to harsh braking.
There's a little
accelerometer built in there.
And we even got a gyro as well.
One of the things that
we've got in the port
of the little device
is the ability
to connect up third
party sensors as well.
So it really transforms
the commercial vehicle
into this IoT hub.
And all of this data streams
into the GCP platform.
And what you're
seeing here is really
a point cloud of a
single day's worth
of driving of all
the fleets that are
equipped with Geotab vehicles.
And that's 1 and 1/2
million vehicles right now
across the globe and
streaming in 30 billion data
points on a daily basis.
So we're doing that
all through GCP.
So what's the
problem we're trying
to solve for here right now?
This isn't the traditional
fleet manager problem.
But it's a little bit different.
It's looking at a fleet.
And how can I decide
which vehicles
I'm going to place
these air quality
sensors on such that I can
leverage this amazing solution
that Aclima has created?
But it's not only which
vehicles to put it on.
It's which fleets.
Which fleets are best
serviced for this?
So in order determine
that, we've actually
developed some really cool
machine learning algorithms
that take the driving
patterns of vehicles
and transform them into
different vocations.
We've got 35,000 customers--
garbage trucks, police
vehicles, couriers, you name it.
So we have to first understand
how these vehicles are
moving around cities.
And once we were
able to do that,
we actually ran an
interesting study
with the Environmental
Defense Fund,
which you can see through
this link over here.
And what we were trying
to do is figure out,
for a specific
geographic area, what
are the types of
fleets that will best
maximize geographic coverage?
And again, it's all
available through that link.
But what this is
showing you here
is a story for Washington DC.
And we ran it with one of
our customers, DC Water,
at aggregate.
And this is showing that, over
a period of about six months,
we were able to get 70% coverage
of the entire geography of DC.
And that's using
their public fleet,
whereas you look at the
private sector fleets
and you get about 50%.
And although this is
representative for DC,
we were seeing this
picture more or less
across the board for small,
large municipalities.
And when we talk
about coverage, it's
really important to
understand what we mean
when we say coverage as well.
So we look at coverage
from a geohash perspective.
And for those of you who
aren't familiar with geohashes,
it's a way of dividing up the
earth into various quadrants.
And we look at it at
the geohash 7 level,
which is an alphanumeric
representation
of a specific area.
And the geohash 7 level
represents about 500 feet
by 500 feet.
And when we say
something is covered,
it means it's been covered
by about 15 different passes
through each of these geohashes.
OK.
And that was, again,
through the study with EDF.
Turns out that having municipal
fleet vehicles collect
these air quality sensor
readings is a good thing.
It's good because there's
an incentive to deploy.
There's a duty to serve
back to the public.
We have so many different varied
use cases of these vehicles,
too.
You have public transit buses,
folks in water and wastewater.
And the coverage is so disparate
that we get a really nice
geographic spread.
And then the third thing
is that there's always
a link to the Environmental
and Sustainability Office.
So we typically work with
the fleet operations.
But you bring fleet
together with environment,
and you really have a
great solution here.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to give you an example of
a case study from DC Water.
OK.
And I will take Tim.
Tim is a fleet
manager at DC Water.
He's got about 600 different
vehicles under his control.
OK.
And he's been tasked
with figuring out
which vehicles are
going to be best suited
for looking at integration
of the Aclima platform,
which of his vehicles he
needs to put these on.
I mean, he's already inundated
with safety, and compliance,
and productivity issues.
He needs a simple tool
to be able to figure
out which of these vehicles
that he needs to put this on.
OK.
And you might ask,
well, why doesn't he
just outfit the entire
fleet of 600 vehicles?
Well, first, that would
be cost prohibitive.
And second of all,
we've proven that he
doesn't need to do that.
He can do it on a smaller
segment of vehicles
to understanding their
movement patterns.
Now imagine that you've
got thousands of Tims.
We've got 35,000
customers, thousands
in the municipal fleet sector.
We need something that's going
to scale really, really well.
We can't just do it for
Tim and expect to be done.
So I'm going to walk you through
our process of ingesting all
of this data,
transforming it, exploring
it, which is really important--
I think the most
important step--
and then developing a solution
that works well, a very, very
scalable approach.
So I'm going to flip back about
two years, three years to 2016
where we were monitoring
400,000 vehicles.
The old way we looked
at this-- so the vehicle
will communicate over
the cellular network.
It will send data
through to our gateway
servers, which sit on GCP.
That then goes through
to our streaming server
again on Compute Engine.
And through streaming
to BigQuery,
we're able to get
that data to BigQuery
within 5 to 10 seconds.
So for 400,000 vehicles,
from the time the data hits
our gateway servers
to the time it's
available in BigQuery is
about 5 to 10 seconds.
Problem is, as we started to
approach a million vehicles,
that really started
to slow down.
So we've got these
dashboards across the board
in our entire organization
that allow us to see what's
going on within our ecosystem.
And we were seeing that
5 to 10 seconds jump up
to 11 minutes, 20
minutes, an hour.
I mean, thank goodness
we had the foresight
to see this coming about.
And we decided a new
approach was really needed.
And that new approach is
what we're doing today.
So we've got about 1 and
1/2 million vehicles,
again, streaming through
the cellular network
to our gateway servers.
Segmented files are sent
through to Cloud Storage.
And then we've got
Kubernetes Engine
that picks up all of this data.
So we've got 36 different
pods in Kubernetes
that are picking
up all this data
and then pushing
it into BigQuery
using streaming inserts.
And then we're able to maintain
that 5 to 10 second lag.
So that worked
exceptionally well for us.
Kubernetes gave us the ability
to scale really, really well.
And we can dynamically scale
it up and down as needed.
So now that we've
done the ingestion,
time comes for transformation.
So I mention we've got 30
billion records coming in
on a daily basis.
About a third of that is GPS,
so 10 billion GPS records.
Now, in order to
develop this tool that's
going to be really useful to
be able to figure out which
vehicles we want to
deploy, I don't need access
to the raw data.
I need access to some
transformed data.
So then we
transformed this data.
The raw data comes in
the form of the vehicle,
the speed, the GPS.
We're getting every single
entry, so 10 billion
of these entries coming in.
Then what we do is we throw
it into Cloud Composer.
So essentially, we started
off with Apache Airflow,
then moved to Composer
because it scaled really well.
And then what we're
doing is we're
taking the data from BigQuery
and essentially putting it back
into BigQuery through Composer.
That works really well.
We use this process a lot
throughout the organization.
And now we've transformed
it into a way where we've
got the metrics by Geohash.
And we can pull
those out directly
from BigQuery in the
application that we push out.
Exploration of data
is absolutely crucial.
And BigQuery and BQGIS have
been phenomenal for this for us.
So if anybody's done any
interpretation of GIS data
at scale, you know it's
difficult to put a ton of data
onto a map.
So what we've done is we've
developed a tool leveraging
deck.gl that allows us to put
millions of points on a map
and be able to analyze that.
So I can throw a
query into this--
so this is the tool right here--
into the side and then have
it visualized immediately.
And this is great because all of
a sudden my data scientists who
have been running Colab
and Jupyter Notebooks now
have the ability to
write a single query
with geospatial context and
visualize it immediately.
All you need to
know is SQL, which
is really, really powerful.
And as a quick example
of what we did here
during the exploration
process, we literally
mapped all of the
coverage within DC.
And we decided, wouldn't it be
interesting to take open data
from DC and plot where all
the schools are, and see
if we can find an
intersection, if we
were to deploy
these sensors, where
we would be missing
from a coverage
perspective on schools?
So we ran a quick
intersect statement
over here leveraging SQL.
And it pulled out
that data immediately.
So again, leveraging
BigQuery, BQGIS
has been transformational from
a data exploration perspective.
And we didn't stop there.
We wanted to understand
what kinds of vehicles
would elicit the best coverage.
And ideally, we've got
vehicles that would be electric
or hybrid going across the
globe here to do these readings.
But turns out, in
many fleets, that's
still a small percentage.
So if we were do
it for DC Water,
we'd get about 14% coverage,
which isn't so great.
We look at Diesel, we
get about 44% coverage,
gas, 59% coverage.
And if you look at a
consolidated approach,
you get about 70% coverage.
OK.
So again, it does
warrant the need
to have more of these hybrid
and electric vehicles,
I think, within
communities for us
to be able to do some
really cool stuff.
So now that we've finished
this as we've done ingestion,
we did transform, we did
explore, now it's time
to actually develop something.
OK?
So what we've got
at Geotab, we've
got a marketplace not
dissimilar to an app store.
And I task our MVP team, which
is our minimum viable product
team, to develop an application.
And this was probably
about a two to three
week initiative for them,
which was pretty incredible.
And they were able
to leverage BQGIS
and develop a tool that now
could go out to our 35,000
different customers to allow
them to assess whether or not
they've got good
coverage and which
vehicles they need
to equip to be
able to integrate with Aclima.
And there are two primary
use cases that we looked at.
One was for city-wide coverage.
So it's looking at,
well, what coverage
can I get from across
my entire city?
Am I missing important areas?
And these important
areas could be
augmented with data available
from Aclima's system as well.
And more importantly
as well, too,
which areas aren't covered?
Are there important
school zones,
important areas
that aren't getting
covered by this mapping?
So what I'm going
to do is I'm just
going to show you a quick
demo here of the application.
All right.
So what we're looking
at here is the add-in.
And so we've got DC's kind
of boundaries drawn here.
I'm going to run just a very
quick analysis for you here.
So it's going to be from
October through December
at an aggregate
level for DC Water.
And what it's doing
in the back end--
and I've staged some data here.
That's why it was so quick--
we're pulling off
queries from BigQuery,
leveraging BQGIS as well.
And what this is telling me
here now is, from October
to December, I've
got 55% coverage
with 30 vehicles in this area.
Vehicle 8619, it's
a light duty truck.
It represents about 81%
of that 55% coverage.
If I zoom in here, I'm able
to quickly see each geohash.
And each geohash that
is represented there
means it's been covered, so
at least 15 or more passes.
The lighter the color, the
fewer vehicles that were there.
So you can clearly
see the major arteries
by the number of
vehicles that are just
shown in a deeper color.
In addition, I've got this
pretty cool little chart
over here that shows my
coverage percentage by number
of vehicles.
So if I have 30
vehicles, which I do,
15 passage represents that 55%
that you were seeing up there.
If I scroll up to here,
I get 50 vehicles.
I get about 61% coverage.
So I can look at
by number of passes
and by number of
vehicles as well.
Now let's say I
want to maybe look
at-- this was for a
three month time period.
Maybe I can get some better
data and some better coverage
if I look at it over a
six month time period.
So if I do that, I jump
up from 55% to about 65%
here, which isn't too bad.
What I can also do is I can have
a look at filtering this data
a little bit more.
So I could do it by number
of passes if I wanted.
If I want to augment the
vehicles from 30 to 50 vehicles
and apply that filter, you can
see that my percentage jumps up
to about 70% coverage as well.
So it becomes a business
decision at this point in time
as well.
Is it worth deploying another
20 vehicles for a 5% increase?
Maybe I can leverage
some of the data
available from Aclima's platform
to make up that difference as
well, too.
So it gives you a
good way to explore
which vehicles are going to be
the best to give you coverage.
The last thing I
want to show you
here was that notion of looking
at which areas aren't covered.
So we've imported,
again, the public school
data from open DC.
And if I click this
little icon here,
we're running that
intersects query over BQGIS.
And it's looking for an
intersection of areas
where schools aren't covered.
So I've identified a
handful of schools here
that wouldn't be covered
if I were doing that.
And if I looked at a major
kind of throughfare here,
this is near a freeway.
I could see that this
particular school here
isn't immediately covered.
Its surrounding
neighborhoods are.
But it's River Terrace
Education, about 131 kids there
that wouldn't have coverage.
So one potential is you might
put a stationary sensor there.
Or again, it might be some data
you could leverage from Aclima
to make that complete coverage.
And without further ado, I'm
going to bring Davida back
on stage here.
And she's going to talk to
us about the amazing solution
that the folks at
Aclima have as well.
DAVIDA HERZL: Great.
Thank you, Mike.
So when it comes to
measuring air quality,
it's really important to
take a multi-pollutant view
so that we can understand
emissions and pollution
at a really granular level.
Aclima measures
what matters when
it comes to air pollution,
emissions, and climate change
emissions, everything from
carbon dioxide and ozone,
to black carbon, methane,
and particulate matter.
We've been heavy users of
GCP for the past seven years.
And we actually started
using Google Cloud tools
before Google Cloud
was a separate group.
So we've been really
dedicated users of GCP.
And during that time, we built
a lot of custom infrastructure
along the way.
But we're really happy to
announce that we've now
adopted GCP tools
across our stack,
from BigQuery, and Cloud
Storage, Cloud SQL, Kubernetes,
Google IoT, Pub/Sub, and
a whole breath of tools
from the GCP platform,
which has really
allowed us to focus on
what Aclima does best.
And we've, in that
process, reduced
the complexity of
our DevOps operation
and reduced costs by 65%.
And as heavy users
of BigQuery, we're
taking advantage of
the new GIS functions
to simplify complex
querying and aggregation
to prepare for the
downstream analysis that
occurs when we ingest
all of that data
and then really work to help
our customers make sense
of that data.
And we're also really
happy to announce today
that we are now a cloud
SAS partner, enabling
us to bring the
best of everything
that Aclima and Google have
to offer to our customers.
Our services are offered
primarily through our SAS
platform through Aclima Pro.
Aclima Pro is a
paid premium service
that allows public and private
sector customers in government
and the enterprise to access,
analyze, query complex
and dense air quality
and climate emissions
data sets to better inform
a wide range of decisions
to reduce emissions and
improve air quality.
We also have a freemium
service that we
offer to communities
and to citizens
that turns all of that
complex information into data,
or all of that complex
data into information
that the public can consume
in a really intuitive way that
enables broad public awareness
and engagement with air
quality in our communities.
The benefits of the
Aclima platform are broad.
There is a broad
range of capabilities
that the platform
enables our customers--
empowers our customers to do.
But fundamentally, it
comes down to really
being able to diagnose
problems at the city scale.
So I often say
that we're creating
a wearable for the city
so that we can actually
diagnose what's happening,
why it's happening,
identify hotspots and
sources, reveal hotspots
for human exposure so that then
we can actually take action,
and once we take
action, understand
the benefits of that
the ROI on the decisions
that we've taken as cities--
as users of the platform.
And so, as an
example-- and I think
one of the most powerful
examples that we've seen,
again, comes down to some of
our most impacted populations.
So when you're a
city and you have
to make a decision
about where to invest
public funds to protect
school children, who are often
the most affected by
pollution, they're
having to do that in the blind,
so without any data whatsoever.
But what the platform
enables our city users to do
is to target those funds in
a way that really targets
those areas that
are most impacted
and benefits the broadest
number of citizens and children.
So with that I'm very
excited to pass the mic over
to John Walton from San Mateo.
I'm really excited to be
working with you, John.
JOHN WALTON: Good
morning, everybody.
First just let me say
thank you all for coming.
And I'm really honored
to be part of this group.
They invited me to come
and talk a little bit.
They are the type
of smart people
I wanted to be when
I went to college.
And it turned out I
wasn't smart enough
to be as successful
as they were.
So I went into
government instead.
And it's great to
be here, though.
Before I went to
San Mateo County,
I was actually the CIO
here in San Francisco
for about six years.
So I've just moved one
county closer to where
I live down in Monterrey.
When we were putting
this deck together,
they asked me if I had the
rights to all the pictures,
because we all do slide shows.
And people are asking me,
can we show these pictures?
And I'm happy to say we do have
all the rights in our county's
pictures.
And actually, the picture of
the young child is my son.
And so this is the first
time in my career--
and I've been doing
this for about 25 years.
This kind of brought a lot of
different things in my life
together, which is why I'm
so excited to be here today.
So a little bit about me.
And I know we don't have a lot
of time, so I want to be brief.
But I started out as a kid.
My big passion as a child, I
want to be a forest ranger.
I wanted to be in science.
That's what I loved.
I love the environment.
It's always been my passion.
And so when I started school,
that's what I wanted to do.
I went to Humboldt
State University.
So if you've ever been up
to Northern California,
you know it's a big
environmental area.
And that's why I went
there, because it
was all about the environment.
I had some very idealistic
views that I still hold
today, by the way.
A lot of the groups
we've talked about--
environmental
groups-- I probably
single-handedly kickstarted a
lot of those when I was young.
And when I started
college, I was doing GIS.
Back then it was on a VAX.
I was taking LANsat imagery.
I was doing vegetation
stress indexes,
trying to figure out what to do.
I was mapping spotted owl
habitat, marbled mirror habitat
up in the north coast.
And so early, early on in
my life and in my career,
I was convinced that taking
data and applying it--
good data-- in a way where
you could visualize it and get
people to relate to
what was going on
around them in a personal
level and a local level
was really what helped us make
good decisions as a community,
as a society, and drive change.
And so that was really
how I kind of started
my whole journey down this
path of really believing that.
So I got out of college.
I was going to be an engineer.
But it turned out
I didn't really
love calculus and
fluid dynamics.
So I went more the natural
side and did a lot of hydrology
and things like that.
But I got out of college.
And it was during
the Reagan era.
There was no jobs in
the environmental area.
Go figure.
And I got hired by
a county because I
knew how to set up computers.
So that's how I
got into computers,
because I was setting up all
the computers in college.
And really, it took
off from there.
So I tell everybody,
if you to be
the CIO of a government
someday, go to Humboldt State,
get your degree in natural
resources planning,
and you'll be set.
You're on the track to be
a world famous CIO someday
in government.
But fast forward now,
25 years later to
where we are today,
in San Mateo County,
if you think about our county,
we're 800 square miles.
Well, 500.
Sorry.
500 square miles, about
800,000 people in our county.
For those of you that
aren't from around here,
we're kind of the forgotten
county between San Francisco
and San Mateo.
So our county actually
goes all the way
from the southern border
of San Francisco, which
is about 50 square miles,
everything south of there--
matter of fact, San Francisco
Airport is in my county.
They pay us rent,
which we love--
and goes all the way
down to Palo Alto.
We get the poor side.
We get East Palo Alto.
They get Stanford
down in Santa Clara.
But on the coast side,
it goes all the way down,
almost to Santa Cruz.
So we have a very
diverse county.
On what we call the bay
side, the 101 corridor,
you have 22 different cities
all down that corridor.
Just amazing amount of
urban, really dense.
Probably a lot of you that work
here in the Bay Area, probably
your CEOs or founders
probably live in my county--
Woodside, Atherton, Menlo Park.
Those are all in my county.
So we have this very
interesting, very dense,
very technically savvy
engaged population.
Now, if you go over 280, if
you've been down in our county,
and you go to the
west side, it's
all agricultural,
all mountainous, all
very different.
Now, early on in
the presentation,
you saw a slide showing where
the sensor locations are.
If you think it's challenging
for San Francisco, which
is 50 square miles, to only
have one sensor in there county,
we're 500 square miles.
And I have one
sensor in my county.
And it's on the bay
side in Redwood City.
So if you live in Half Moon
Bay, which is on the coast,
and you're trying to understand
what the air quality is
like in your neighborhood based
on a sensor in Redwood City,
you're probably not going to
see a really good correlation
between your real
world experience
and the stuff you're seeing as
the official air quality index.
So that's how we got engaged
here with Google, and Aclima,
and Geotab, because we were
convinced in the county
that we needed to
engage partners
like them to really
understand what
was going on with
our environment
to make things better for our
communities at a local level.
So we launched about a year ago
now an initiative in our county
called SMC Labs.
Government, as some
of you may know,
isn't known for
how fast we move.
So we created this
innovation group.
They engaged with our partners.
We have signed an
agreement with them,
which we're very excited about.
We see this as the way to really
start understanding-- given
the fact that we
have 22 cities, we
have a huge fleet
of vehicles, we
manage over 1,000 vehicles
for public safety,
for public health, we
manage SamTrans vehicles
that do the bus routes
all over our county,
we think this is a
great opportunity
to use a combination of
Geotab and Aclima data
to really start understanding
what's going on in our county.
Because these
problems we're trying
to solve in the
real world, they're
not specific to an invisible
political boundary.
The problems around
air quality don't
stop when you
cross from one city
to another when
they're all together.
There's really a
regional problem
we're trying to solve--
we're trying to engage on.
All of us probably have
loved ones or people
we care about in schools.
When we had the fires--
one of my other
part time jobs, I'm
a trustee on a school board.
But when we were having the
fires up in the North Bay,
that wasn't just a
North Bay problem.
Granted, I mean, that was
horrific for the people
up in the North Bay.
But the huge plume of
smoke went offshore
because of the wind currents
and came in over our county.
And it was really
eye opening just
to see how impactful
that was to how
people perceive their quality
of life and things like that.
There was people calling our
hospitals, sheltering in place.
Schools were closing.
I mean, it really caused
sort of this ancillary impact
to the community, to our
whole region for a while,
that I think you're
always concerned
about the people who's
losing their houses, who's
losing their lives.
But it really brought home to
all of us how we're all in this
together.
And we have to solve
these problems together.
And air quality is just, I
think, one of those really easy
to understand, important
values that we can look at,
that we can track.
And I think-- my hope
is in the coming months,
as we continue to
explore and expand
this partnership with Google,
and with Aclima, and Geotab,
and we start to deploy
more of this technology,
as we start to do some of
this analysis, as we create
these great interactive maps
and visualizations that we can
share with politicians
and the community
about what the current condition
is in their neighborhoods
and what they can do, and
policies and actions we can
take based on data,
that that's really
going to start helping us make
changes in our communities
here in the Bay Area, and
then launch to other places.
I know this is already going on.
We were just in Denver last week
at a Smart Cities Conference,
and they're talking about it.
I think this is just really
the tip of the iceberg where,
in a few years,
this is just going
to be the norm for everything.
So I really appreciate
you all being here.
You're the brains
behind all this.
And I'm going to hand
it back over to Chad.
CHAD JENNINGS: Alrighty.
So I wanted to,
first off, thank you
all for going with
us on the journey.
We've handed the mic off
a whole bunch of times.
In the handbook for
presenting at this conference,
they say not to do that.
But really, the story spanned
a whole bunch of organizations
and a whole bunch of use cases.
And it was really
important to make
sure to bring John on so
that he could explain who
the people are that
benefit from the maps
that Mike and Davida are making.
So thank you very
much for coming.